شكرا لزميل ابراهيم ساعه اخباريه جديده من
العربيه اهلا بكم نبدا باهم عناوينها
مواجهات متفرقه في الخرطوم تخرق الهدنه
والجيش يحبط هجوما للدعم السريعي شمال
كردفان
مصر تبلغ مفوضيه اللاجئين بدخول اكثر من
56 الف سودانيين الى اراضيها منذ بدء
الاشتباكات
وفي اخبارنا ايضا
يصف الهجوم على الكرملين بالعمل العدائي
ويتوعد بان روسيا سترد بخطوات ملموسه
لندن تستكمل استعدادها لحفل تتويج الملك
تشارلز الثالث بانتظار بدء توافد زعماء
العالم
[موسيقى]
اذا تشهد العاصمه السودانيه مواجهات
متقطعه منذ ساعات الصباح الاولى وذلك بعد
اعلان الطرفين الموافقه على هدنه جديده
لاثنتين وسبعين ساعه وافاد بان سلاح الجو
السوداني نفذ طلعات جويه في محيط الاذاعه
والتلفزيون وجنوب مدينه ام درمان
هذا هو اعلنت شبكه الاتصالات ام تي ان
توقف خدمتها في الخرطوم عن العمل وذلك
بسبب توقف مقسمات الشركه في الخرطوم عن
العمل ادى لانقطاع جميع الخدمات عن
المشتركين جراء انقطاع الامداد الكهربائي
وقالت الشركه انها تعمل على استعاده
خدماتها وايجاد حلول باقرب وقت
قبل ذلك اكد الدعم السريع في بيان قبوله
تمديد الهدنه لاثنتين وسبعين ساعه بوساطه
سعوديه امريكيه والالتزام بوقف اطلاق
النار كما اعلن الدعم السريع ترحيبه
بالمبادرات المحليه والاقليميه والدوليه
لوقف اطلاق النار بهدف فتح ممرات انسانيه
وتسهيل حركه المواطنين
ومع استمرار خرق الهدنه في السودان اعلن
الجيش السوداني في بيان الله عن احباط
هجوم لقوات الدعم السريع على مدينه
الاوبيض شمال كردوفان حيث توجد ثاني اكبر
حاميه عسكريه في البلاد وفرض سيطره كامله
على المدينه البيان اوضح ان قوه من الجيش
اشتبكت مع الدعم السريع وكبدتهم خسائر
كبيره في الارواح مع تدمير ثلاث مركبات
اضاف الجيش السوداني ان دعم سريع شنه
هجوما على معسكر تدريب في جبل كوردوفان
اصفر عن مقتل 15 عسكريا بينهم اثنان من
الضباط كما لاحقت مجموعات من الهجانه
التابعه للجيش عناصر الدعم السريع في عدد
من شوارع وازقه المدينه وفق البيان
من الخرطوم ينضموا الينا الصحفي عمار ابو
شيبه عمار مرحبا بك معي في هذه الساعه
عمار بدايه نريد الحديث عن هذه الطلعات
الجويه فوق العاصمه الخرطوم اين تركزت
وكذلك هل كانت هذه الطائرات بهدف
الاستهداف ام الاستطلاع
نعم يعني هذه الطلعات الجويه كانت منذ
الصباح الباكر الان وفي هذه اللحظات عدد
من الطائرات المقاتله عادت من جديد لسماء
الخرطوم وربما تنفذ عددا من الطلعات
وتستهدف عدد من الاهداف المتحركه وغير
المتحركه في منطقه بحري وهذه المنطقه التي
تعرف بحله حمد او منطقه البابورات وهذه
المنطقه تتواجد فيها قوات الدعم السريع
وهي مطله على القصر الرئاسي من الجانب
الشمالي
لمدينه بحري
والجانب المحاذي للقصر الرئاسي على النيل
وهذه المنطقه تستخدمها قوات الدعم السريع
كحصنه وتحصينات من خلالها فيها كثير جدا
من القوات وكثير جدا من المضادات الارضيه
للطيران هذه الطلعات تكثفت في هذه المنطقه
منذ صباح الباكر وما زلنا نستمع لدويا
الانفجارات في هذه اللحظات وعدد من
المضادات الارضيه
وللمعلوميه هذه المنطقه هي بالقرب من جسر
الماك نمر وهذا الجسر ايضا تقترب منه بشكل
واضح هي محطه مياه بحريه التي تنقطع فيها
المياه منذ اكثر من 20 يوم من بدايه
الصراع هذه الطلعات ايضا ما زالت تستمر في
وسط العاصمه الخرطوم ربما قبل قليل نفذت
عدد من الطلعات في منطقه محيط المطار وفي
منطقه ام درمان كان هذا لافتا من خلال هذه
الطلعات الجويه التي تتركز الان في سماء
الخرطوم وبالشكل مباشر على مدينه بحري طيب
السؤال ايضا كذلك عن عوده الاشتباكات او
عن سماع ايضا دوي انفجارات او حتى اطلاق
رصاص في العاصمه الخرطوم لا اتحدث عن
ساعات الصباح الاولى تحدث عن الساعه
الماضيه عمار ان كان هناك من اي رصد جديد
على الارض يبدو ان هنالك تحشيدا عسكريا قد
تم قبل ساعات ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه لم ترد
الينا معلومه فيما يخص اشتباكات مواجهه
مباشره على الارض الان الاشتباكات ما بين
سلاح الطيران والمضادات الارضيه وعدد من
المدافع التي تتواجد في تلك المناطق منطقه
حله حمد ومنطقه البابورات بمنطقه بحري وهي
المطله على القصر الرئاسي وعلى شارع النيل
بشكل واضح ومباشر لكن المواجهات لم تذهب
الى مواجهات مباشره مثلما كانت بالامس
واول الامس بشكل على الارض بشكل مواجهه
مباشره حتى هذه اللحظه هذه اللحظه الطيران
هو سيد الموقف سلاح الجوي شنهجمات ترد
المضادات الارضيه عليه من خلال عدد من
التحصينات والدفاعات التي تستخدمها قوات
الدعم وكذلك ماذا عن توقف خدمات الانترنت
يعني مزود الاتصالات تحديدا شركه ام تي ان
اعلنت عن توقف خدماتها في
الخرطوم بسبب ع طر في مقسمات الشركه ماذا
لديك من معلومات حول توقف الخدمات خدمات
الاتصالات والانترنت في العاصمه الخرطوم
عمار
نعم منذ اليوم الاول شبكات الاتصالات
المزوده لخدمات الانترنت وخدمات الاتصالات
كانت تعاني جراء الاشتباكات المتقطعه
والمتفرقه في عدد كبير من انحاء العاصمه
وحتى على مستوى الولايات وبعد مرور هذا
الوقت الطويل 20 يوما من عمر الحرب الان
شركه ام تي ان سودان وهي شركه مزوده لخدمه
الاتصالات لعدد كبير من المشتركين لديها
اشارت في بيان لها بانها لا تستطيع ان
توفر الخدمه نسبه لانقطاع الكهرباء ونسبه
لعدم مقدرتها لايصال الوقود لعدد من محطات
التغذيه والتقويه في كثير جدا من الاحياء
والتي دخلت ضمن دائر او دائره الاشتباكات
بشكل واضح وهذا يدل على ان هذه الشركه
الان لا تستطيع ان تقدم هذه الخدمه شركات
اتصالات اخرى
تقدم ايضا خدمات ما زالت تعاني ايضا من
ذات النقطه ولكن لم تتوقف بشكل واضح
الشبكه الان تنقطع لحظات ومن ثم تعود في
عمليه تردي واضحه لكثير جدا من المستخدمين
وحتى على مستوى كثير جدا من الذين تحدثنا
اليهم تحدثوا بشكل واضح وهذا ايضا ما
نشاهده حتى على مستوى الهواتف النقاله
وعلى كثير جدا من شبكات الهاتف التي من
خلالها يتواصل الجميع هنالك انقطاع
للخدمات مره ومن ثم تعود من جديد وهذا
ايضا واضح من خلال هذه اللحظات التي تدور
فيها كم حجم كم حجم او عدد الولايات
السودانيه التي تاثرت سواء بانقطاع
الكهرباء او ايضا حتى بتاثر خدمات
الاتصالات والانترنت
نعم يعني منذ الامس منذ ليل الامس كان
هنالك حديث ومعلومات مؤكده عن انقطاع
الكهرباء في عدد في اكثر من ست ولايات
مباشره في هذه النقطه وهذا ايضا وضح من
خلال بيان الجيش الذي اتهم القوات الدعم
السريع بالسيطره على محطات التحكم
للكهرباء مما ادى الى انقطاع الكهرباء عن
عدد كبير من الاحياء وامتدت لاكثر من سته
ولايات على مستوى ولايه الخرطوم عدد من
المناطق تتاثر منذ اليوم الاول بانقطاع
الكهرباء والتي اصلا فيها نقص منذ فتره
طويله وهذا ايضا يؤثر على خدمات اخرى مثل
الاتصالات وعدد من الخدمات المصرفيه وعدد
من الخدمات الاقتصاديه وهذا ايضا اثر بشكل
واضح على المراكز الصحيه والمستشفيات التي
اعلنت من خلال عده بيانات بانها لا تستطيع
ان تجري عدد من العمليات وان تقدم الخدمات
الصحيه في ظل انقطاع الكهرباء هذا يؤثر
ايضا في عمليه التحرك داخل احياء العاصمه
الخرطوم التي يمكن التحرك فيها عدد من
الشوارع الفرعيه تنقطع فيها الكهرباء
وتعود وحتى يؤثر على عمليه التواصل وعمليه
الاطمئنان على بعض الاهل والاقارب في
مناطق كثيره جدا من العاصمه انقطاع
الكهرباء يعود مره ومن ثم ومن ثم تنقطع من
جديد وهذا ايضا واضح من خلال كثير من
الحالات التي رصدناها بالذين يشيرون لان
الكهرباء قد قطعت لديهم ولا يستطيع عدد
كبير من المواطنين الان شراء حتى خدمات
الكهرباء نسبه لان عدد من التطبيقات
البنكيه التي من خلالها يستطيعون الشراء
تتوقف وتتاثر ايضا بحركه الاتصالات
والكهرباء اشكرك جزيل الشكر من الخرطوم
انضم الينا الصحه في عمار ابو شيبه شكرا
عمار
اذا حذر عدد من المتطوعين والناشطين بجنوب
دارفور اثناء تنفيذ حمله صحيه بمستشفى
نياله تعليمي من عمليه تسريح الشباب داخل
الاحياء باقليم دارفور بحجه حمايتها
معتبرين ان الخطوه يمكنها ان تؤدي الى
انزلاق البلاد في شبح الحرب الاهليه في ظل
انعدام الامن بدرفور
جراء المعارك بين الجيش ودعم السريع بجنوب
دارفور احترقت عده اسواق كانت في مرمى
النيران سوق التوابل بجنوب دارفور من اكبر
الاسواق في غرب افريقيا واقدمها تحول الى
رماد بسبب الاشتباكات نتابع
يعتبر سوق التوابل بمدينه نيالا غربيه
السودان احد اكبر الاسواق في غرب افريقيا
واعرقها هنا في اقليم دارفور القذائف التي
سقطت عليه جراء الاشتباكات بين الجيش
والدعم السريع في احداثي 15 من ابريل حولت
السوق الى رماد الخسائر كبيره بحسب حديثه
لجنه الحصر احنا الان في سوق الشطه يعني
الخسائر بتاعتنا تفوق التريليون حجم
البضائع اضافه لذلك المباني
والممتلكات الخاصه
والمستندات وكل التفاصيل انتهت الان تحت
الركام يعني
لا نقول الا ما يرضي الله انا لله وانا
اليه راجعون على الرغم من الدمار
يحاول عيسى موسى اصلاح المكان وتلبيه
احتياجات زبائن رغم من المعاناه والتعب
ولابد لنا من انه المقدح ونعمل لاعاده
تاهيل السوق
ولكي نكسب ونعيش وناهل نفسنا ونرمي ما
تدمر من جراء الحرب في مجتمع يكابد للخروج
من ازمات عديده تاتي هذه الحرب هنا في
اقليم دارفور لتضيف عبئا اخر على حياته
في صالح ابو علامه سيد صالح مرحبا بك معي
في هذه الساعه اريد ان اسال اولا عن دقه
وصحه هذه المعلومات عن تسريح الشباب في
دارفور او ربما حتى يعني اقل من الشباب
نتحدث عن اطفال بحجه حمايتهم هل لمست هذا
هل شاهدته ايضا وكيف تتم هذه العمليه ان
كان صحيحا
نعم في ظل الاعلام الامن بالمدن وبالاحياء
بعض الشباب الى عمل المكاريس وحفر الخنادق
داخل الاحياء في الطرق المؤديه الى
الاحياء بهدف
وايضا منع دخول البضائع التي تنهب من
الاسواق وتنهب من بعض المحلات الطرفيه
والسيارات ايضا من دخول الاحياء نعم لمسنا
هنالك
سلاح
عندما سالنا
بعض
السلاح قالوا بانهم
استفادوا ايضا من خدمات خدامه المحاربين
في الاحياء بهدف عمليه حمايه الاحياء
عمليات السلك والنعم يعني يتم تدريبهم من
قبل المحاربين القدام الموجودين في دارفور
صالح
[موسيقى]
من كيفيه استخدام السلاح استفاده من كيفيه
الحراسه كيفيه
الاستخدام السلاح كيفيه حمايه الاحياء
وهكذا حتى هنالك من يمتلك سلاح
يمنحه للشباب بهدف حمايه الاحياء
بعض الشباب
هنالك عدد اثنين من الشباب قتلوا في مدينه
نيالا هنالك
شاب قتل في مدينه الجنينه ايضا بسبب
الشباب الذين يسمونه بالدروس
حين يعملون على حمايه الاحياء هذه الخطوه
البعض عبر عنها بانها خطره يمكن لهذا
السلاح ان يكون يدخل في عمليه التطفسيات
يدخل في عمليه الاقتتال بين الشباب هنالك
ايضا سلوك يمارس الشباب يقبضون على من
يسمى المتفلتين او معتاديه الاجرام ويتم
ضرب هؤلاء
الشرطه عندما يذهب اليها هؤلاء الشباب
الشرطه ليست لديها مكان للتحفظ على
المجرمين وليست لديها ايضا اي سلطات تقوم
هل هناك اصلا صالح وجود
للشرطه في دارفور يعني من المفترض ان
الشرطه هي من تؤمن الاسواق يعني
تتواجد في مغاراتها هنالك شرطه الاسواق
مثلا في جنوب دارفور هنالك قوات الاحتياط
المركزي التابعه للشرطه في في غرب دارفور
تنتشر انتشار
السوق بهدف تامين السوق بعد عمليات السلب
والنهب التي طالت الاسواق لا يوجد
عمليه امنيه كبيره بالمعنى هنالك
عمليه انتشار في بعض الاماكن بهدف التامين
الشرطه لا تستطيع ان تؤمن كل هذا الخلل
الكبير
الامني جراء المعارك بين الجيش قدام
السريع نعلم بان الجيش والدعم السريع في
السابق كان يعملان مع بعض في عمليه الامس
في عمليه التامين المداخل في عمليه تامين
في حمايه المزارعين وغيرها والروحل وغيرها
من الفئات في لكن الان بعد هذه الحركه
هنالك انفراد كبير في عمليه الامن هنالك
عمليات سلب ونهض في الطرقات المؤديه ما
بين الولايات هذا الشيء ايضا نضيف معاناه
اخرى حين يتعلق بالسلع الاساسيه فيما
يتعلق بالتنقل المواطنين من بعض
الولايات الى الولايات اكثر امنا في اقليم
دارفور فضلا عن السلاح الذي ربما يدخل
بثور اكبر ونحن نعلم بان جليندا فتح على
ليبيا منفتح على اجساد منفتح ايضا على
جنوب السودان كل
هذه العباره تحتاج ايضا لمراقبه بهدف ضبط
الوقود ضد السلع الاساسيه هنالك تهريب يتم
الان هنالك ارتفاع في اسعار الوقود في
معظم
دارفور زياده ملحوظه لاحظناها خلال الايام
الماضيه هنالك سوق اسود للوقود هذا ما
يفاغب من الازمه ازمه المواصلات ازمه
الحركه داخل
اشكرك جزيل الشكر على كل هذه المعلومات
والتفاصيل التي وفيتنا بها من دارفورد
الصحيحه في صالح ابو علامه
في غضون ذلك قالت المديره التنفيذيه
لليونيسف كاترين راسل ان الوضع في السودان
يتجه نحو كارثه والاطفال يقعون بشكل
متزايد في مرمى النيران مؤكده ان اليونيسف
تلقت تقارير عن مقتل 190 طفلا واصابه 1700
اخرين منذ انطلاع النزاع اضافت راسل انه
يجب ان يتوقف العنف من اجل اطفال السودان
وذلك يشمل وقف جميع الهجمات على المراكز
الصحيه والمدارس والبنيه التحتيه للمياه
والصرف الصحي كما دعت للسماح باستيراد
الامدادات الانسانيه والتجاريه الاساسيه
بما في ذلك الاغذيه والوقود من دون قيود
او عوائق او انقطاع بغض النظر عن من يسيطر
على هذه المناطق واكدت راسل ان اليونس
ابتدعو ايضا الى حل سياسي طويل
للطويل الامدي للاسماء
وطلبت مفوضيه الامم المتحده اللاجئين
او للاجئين الدول المستقبله
للسودانيين اللاجئين بعدم اعادتهم الى
بلادهم بسبب الصراع كما افادت بياناته
المفوضيه الساميه للامم المتحده لشؤون
اللاجئين بان اخر الاحصاءات الوارده من
وزاره الخارجيه المصريه تظهر تدفق اكثر من
56 الف شخص الى البلاد فرارا من صراع
السودان حتى الرابع من مايو الجاري ووفق
مكتب المفوضيه فان من بين هؤلاء الاشخاص
الذين دخلوا البلاد من معبري ارجين وقسطل
ما لا يقل عن
52,500 سوداني ونحو 4000 من جنسيه اخرى
من اسوان جنوب مصر ينضم الينا المحلل
السياسي السوداني عمار عوض سيد عمار مرحبا
بك معي في هذه الساعه دعني ابدا معك اولا
بموضوع اللاجئين السودانيين اليوم نتحدث
عن 150 الف سوداني عبروا الحدود السودانيه
الى مصر برايك هل تتجه الامور الى
صعود اكبر في الارقام اللاجئين والنازحين
الى الحدود السودانيه المصريه وكيف تقيم
اوضاع النازحين خلال فتره ثلاثه اسابيع من
هذه الاشتباكات وبدايه هذه الازمه تفضل
نعم
نحن عبرنا قبل يومين من الحكومه المصريه
لا تالوا جهدا في توفير ما يعين
الذين عبروا الذين وفق سؤالك ان يكون
العدد اكبر هنا في مصر نتيجه لعوامل عديده
اللغه الث قافه المشتركه كثير من الاشياء
بعكس الذين عبروا اذا نظرت الذين عبروا
عبر منطقه جوندور والجلابات الى اثيوبيا
بحسب الخارجيه الاثيوبيه هم وصل عددهم الى
4000 واذا نظرت الى العدد الذي عبر الان
الى مصر يصل الى غرابه المئه الف شخص ذلك
يدل على ان ان هذه هذه الوجهه هي التي
ستكون الاعلى في الاعتبار ان الوجه الاخرى
التي يذهب اليها السودانيين هي تلك الى
مدينه بورسودان ثم الى مدينه جده هذه
مرتبطه باصحاب الجوازات الاجنبيه من لديهم
تاشيرات اقامات عمل غيره بالتالي يجعل
العدد هنالك اقله وبنظر الجهه الاخرى هي
الى جنوب السودان عبر منطقه الرنك
الحدوديه وهي التي غالبا ما يكون الذين
يشتغلون هم الذين يقولون في المنطقه
الجنوب السودان الجديد بالنسبه للوجهه
العسكريه هذه المره السيد عماري الى اين
تتجه بوصله هذا الصراع البوصله الميدانيه
ايضا مع دخولنا الاسبوع الثالث تجدد
الاشتباكات عودتها ايضا في ظل يعني اعلان
طرفي هذه الازمه الالتزام بهدنه الا ثنتين
وسبعين ساعه
نعم
كان القوات الدعم السريعه اليوم تحدثت على
انها
جدد
نا لمتابعين كان كثير من السودانيين
يعملون في ان تكون مده الهدنه لسبع ايام
مثلما كان تنتهي التحالف المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
وجنوب السودان واصدقاء السودان لكن
بالعلوم من الواضح مثل ما قال الرئيس ان
كل طرف من الاطراف ما زال يعتقد انه
بمقدوره ان
يحسن المعركه
عسكريا
شاهد عدد من الشواهد ما زالت ماليزيا او
قوات الدعم تحاول ان تستجلب مقاتلين من
خارج السودان لدعمها
وايضا الوقود من بعض دول الجوار تحديدا
نتحدث عن ليبيا وما زال الجيش السوداني
يحاول ان
[موسيقى]
ابغي ميزان القوى على ما هو عليه التصرفات
وهذا الدعم السريع دعني اشرح لك بسرعه
تصرفات قوات الدعم السريع
بجهه انها هاجمت بالام
س من منطقه بحر العسكريه هي التي يوجد بها
الامداد
للعمليات للجيش السوداني بالتالي يعطينا
اشاره على انها بدات تنقص فيها امدادات
الوقود نتيجه لان الوقود الذي ياتيها من
الحدود الليبيه من منطقه الكفره يبدو انه
تم قطعه بغسله بالطائرات لجات لمهاجمه
منطقه بحري العسكريه ذلك يعني ان وقودها
في تناقص وامداداتها في تناقص ايضا لاحظنا
انه منطقه القياده العامه بعد لا نسمع
عنها اخبار ذلك يعني ايضا ان منطقه
القياده العامه ومنطقه المطار اصبحت الان
تحفظ الجيش السوداني بالاشاره الى السيد
عمار انا انا اشكرك لم يتبقى لدي الكثير
من الوقت شكرا جزيلا لك من اسوان جنوب مصر
المحلل السيسي السوداني عمار عوض
[موسيقى]
والان الى تطورات الوضع في اوكرانيا
والهجوم الاخير على الكرملين
[موسيقى]
على وقع تصاعد المعارك في باخمه شرق
اوكرانيا اطلق مؤسس مجموعه فاجنر ايفيجيني
بريجوجين تصريحات ناريه متهما فيها وزير
الدفاع الروسي
سيرجيو ورئيس الاركان العامه فاليري
جيراسيموف بانهم وراء النقص الكبير في
امدادات السلاح للمجموعه والذي يصل الى
70% حسب وصف بريكوجين ونشرت الدائره
الصحفيه للمجموعه مقطع فيديو يظهر فيه
رئيس مجموعه فاجنر مستاء من الوضع بشكل
كبير ويتحدث وخلفه مجموعه من جثث مقاتله
رئيس مجموعه فاجنر حذر من ان قوته ستغادر
مدينه باخمت في العاشر من مايو الجاري
بسبب عدم تامين وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
الذخيره لقوته وقال بريكوجين ان استمرار
القتال في مدينه باخموت من دون ذخيره امر
لا جدوى منه بالاضافه الى تكبد خسائر بين
مقاتلي باغينر خلال المواجهه في
بحلول التاسع من مايكلن على وشك الاستيلاء
على ضخمه لكن بعد ان راوا هذا التقدم اوقف
البيروقراطيون شبه العسكريين توريد
الذخيره لمنعنا من القيام بذلك يعتقدون
انهم سوف يدخلون التاريخ ابلغت وزير
الدفاع ورئيس هيئه الاركان والقائد الاعلى
رسميا بان رفاقي لن يتكبدوا خسائر غير
مبرره في باخموت بدون ذخيره لذا في العشر
من مايو سننسحب من
اكدت مصادر لوكاله
على نقطه تمركز مدربين اجانب للقوات
الاوكرانيه في منطقه تشيرنيف الاوكرانيه
حيث تجمع او حيث تجمع افراد واسلحه واليات
عسكريه واوكرانيه واضاف المصدر للوكاله ان
القوات المسلحه الروسيه دمرت ايضا
مجموعتين استطلاعيتين تابعتين للقوات
الاوكرانيه وافشل التنفيذ تبادل القوات
الاوكرانيه في اربع وحدات عسكريه في اتجاه
محوري كوبيانس
وينضم الينا من دوناتك مراسل العربيه رائد
الاغبر رائد مرحبا بك معي في هذه الساعه
رائد يعني انت ربما منذ بدايه العمليات في
وانت قريب من الوضع وترصده ميدانيا وصحفيا
لماذا هذه النبره
مؤسس ورئيس فاجنر في هذا التوقيت وما الذي
اختلف في معادله بخموت الان
على من صاحب الفضل في الانتصارات بالفعل
هناك تقدم لقوات فاجنر في مدينه باقمت هذا
ما نلمسه على الارض تعترف به الجهات
الاوكرانيه ايضا لكن لابد ان الرجل قريب
من الواقع ويظهر الصوره الحقيقيه لما يحدث
على الارض بالفعل اذا
نقصت اعداد المقاتلين لديه لن يكمل الطريق
الى اكمال السيطره على باقي متبل سيخسر
مزيد من الاراضي والنقاط ويعود ادراج ربما
فضل الرجل بان يكون خارجا منتصرا بعد
الانجازات التي حققها ويريد ان يسلم مكانه
لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه قال بانه في العاشر
من مايو الحالي سيسلم كل النقاط التي وصل
اليها الحديث عن 90% من اراضي مدينه
باخموت مدينه باخمت كان يتحدث انها حوالي
خمسين
الف مت مربع سيطر على ما اكثر من 47 الف
متر مربع وباقي كيلو مترين ونصف لاكمال
السيطره على بخموت ربما يجدر الذكر ايضا
نايف لو سمحنا لنا الوقت بان الهجمات
المضاده الاوكرانيه التي يعني كانت تتصدر
المشهد في الايام الماضيه ربما انها بدات
حيث الحراك في الجنوب الاوكراني القوات
الاوكرانيه ايضا بدات تتقدم نحو خرسون
هناك حشودات كبيره على اطراف الضفه
الجنوبيه لنهر تتمركز القوات الاوكرانيه
على الضفه الشماليه وتحاول القوات
الاوكرانيه الوصول او قطع النهر عبوره عبر
احدى الجزر هذه الجزيره تصنف رماديه لانه
لا يسيطر عليها اي من الطرفين الاوكراني
او الروسي ولا بد من التذكير ايضا بان
النهر كبير جدا وعريض نهر يصل الى خمسه
كيلومترات لذلك يمكن ان يكون هناك بداخله
جزر تصل الى كيلو متر او كيلو او كيلو
مترين يعني مساحه هذه الجزيره يستطيع احد
الطرفين ان يتخذها نقطه ارتكاز للوصول الى
الطرف الاخر المساله الاخرى هي زابروجيا
المتاخمه لخرسون حيث
اسلفتم عن يعني ضخ مزيد من المياه على
محطه
كخوفكا من اجل رفع منسوب المياه واغراق
المحطه النوويه من اجل الانقضاض عليها بعد
الحشودات الاوكرانيه ايضا في زبروج اعلنت
السلطات المحليه عن حشودات في تلك المنطقه
من اجل الانقضاض على المحطه النوويه
واعاده السيطره عليها لصالح اوكرانيا وكان
ضخ مزيد من المياه من اجل ان تعطل الطرق
على القوات الروسيه الذي ربما تنطلق
لانقاذ هذه المحطه او للدفاع عنها هناك
في المناطق الجنوبيه وقصف عنيف من قبل
القوات الاوكرانيه حسب السلطات او المصادر
العسكريه على مراكز وقواعد الحشودات
الاوكرانيه الحديثه
كثير من التطورات ايضا في دانيسك لكن اعلم
ان الوقت ضيق ربما في النشرات الاخرى نايف
الدقه التفاصيل عن ما يحدث في اوكرانيا
خصوصا في الشرق الاوكراني الذي تتابعه منذ
بدايه هذه الازمه من دوله مراسل العربيه
رائد الاكبر شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
اكد وزير الخارجيه الروسيه يصير فان
الهجوم على الكرملين كان عملا عدائيا
روسيا ستطرد بخطوات ملموسه او سترد بخطوات
ملموسه اعتبر لافروف ان كيف لن تحاول
مهاجمه الكريملين دون اخطار سادتها في
الغرب حسب وصفه كشف وزير الخارجيه الروسي
ايضا ان موسكو مستعده للتحدث مع الغرب
وهذا سيحدث عاجلا ام اجلا
من جانبه حذر نائب وزير الخارجيه
ريابكوف من ان العلاقات الروسيه الامريكيه
تقترب من حافه مواجهه المسلحه مشيرا لان
موسكو تحاول الحفاظ على العلاقات مع
واشنطن لمنع سقوطها في هويه النزاع المسلح
اضافكو فان روسيا مستعده لاستخدام كل
الوسائل الممكنه لضمان عدم السماح لاي جهه
بالتعدي على امن روسيا وسلامه رئيسها
وقيادتها السياسيه
يلتحق بنا مراسل العربيه عبد الجواد الرشد
عبد الجواد مرحبا بك معي في هذه النشره
دعنا نبدا من هذه التصريحات لوزير
الخارجيه الروسي سيرجي لابروف نريد ان
تجمل لنا ابرز ما قاله فيما يخص الهجمات
التي كانت تحاول استهداف الرئيس بوتين في
الكرملين بالاضافه الى العلاقه مع واشنطن
ومصيرها في الايام القادمه
مرحبا نايف نعم صحيح ما تقول تصريحات وزير
الخارجيه الروسي سركيلاف جاءت مماثله لما
تتحدث عنه الاوساط الرسميه في روسيا لكن
بلهجه دبلوماسيه نوعا ما طبعا
يتحدث عن ضروره الحوار يعني كان لابد من
لفت الانتباه هو الكثير من القراءات
السياسيه في البلاد راح تتحدث بعد تصريعات
بان طبعا طاوله المفاوضات يجب ان تكون
متاحه لكن ضمن الشروط التي ترغب موسكو
بمناقشتها وبعدم املاء الوضع يعني الامني
ووضعها الاقليمي في القاره الاوروبيه من
وجهه نظر هؤلاء المحللين طبعا سيرجيلا
وروف تحدث عن امور عده ابرزها طبعا يكمن
في يعني فهمه للموقف كما تحدث وانه مؤمن
بمبدا بان الغرب شام ابا سيجلس الى طاوله
المفاوضات هنا ي طبعا لما بداه نائب مجلس
الامن الروسي وسكرتيره طبعا الرئيس السابق
للبلاد متري ميدفي الذي تحدث بان روسيا
جاهزه لاستخدام اي سلاح لضمان امني بلادها
وضمان يعني امني رئيس البلاد فلاديمير
بوتين لذلك طبعا موسكو تحتفظ كما تحدثت
بحق الرد في الوقت الذي تراه مناسبا
بالطريقه التي تراها مناسبه طبعا راحت بعض
التحليلات نايف تتحدث اليوم عن ان تصريح
نائب رئيس مجلس نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسي
سرقه يختلف بشكل كلي عما تحدث عنه لكن في
نهايه المطاف نرى بان معظم هذه التصريحات
تصب في ان روسيا جاهزه للحوار من جهه
لكنها لن تقف مكتوفه الايدي في حال تعرض
امن بلاد امن البلاد لاي تهديد خارجي
بالرغم من وصفه بان العلاقات بين موسكو و
واشنطن وصلت الى حافه الهاويه حسب ق الا
انه عاد وتحدث عن ان قنوات الاتصالات تجري
بين روسيا والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
خاصه بما يخص الملف السياسي نايف عبد
الجواد فيما يخص الهجوم الذي طال الكيرلي
من خلال اليومين الماضيين يعني هناك ربما
من يسال عن رده الفعل الروسيه التي يعني
على الاقل لم تاتي على قدر الاستهداف يعني
ان كان ان كان ما حدث خلال اليومين
الماضيه من روسيا هو يعني يمكن ان نضعه في
هذه الخانه
روسيا عندما يعني تحدث معها مثل هذه
الازمات او محاوله الاستهداف يعني التي
طلت الكرم كيف تتصرف هل ترد مباشره هل
يكون هناك تريث وبعد ذلك الرد من خلال
سياق العمليات العسكريه الروسيه في
اوكرانيا
طبعا نايف قضيه الرد لما حدث بملف
المسيرتين يعني التي تم اسقاطها فوق
الكرملين مرتبطه بعده امور الملف الاول هو
اجتماع الرئيس الروسي مع مجلس الامن داخل
البلاد القضيه الثانيه هو انشغال موسكو
بقضيه التحضير لعيد النصر والحفل الكبير
الذي ستشهده عده ساحات في مدن البلاد في
التاسع من مايو الجاري ايضا قضيه التحقيق
يعني هو ملف جنائي فتحته موسكو يوم امس
ويستمر التحقيق في هذا الموضوع الجميع
يعرف نوع هذه الطائرات المسيره بعد
الاعلان عنها لكن حتى هذه اللحظه لم يتم
الكشف عن خط سير هذه المسيرات والنقطه
التي انطلقت منها ما هي الاهداف التي سعت
اليها لكن موسكو تحدثت بشكل واضح يوم امس
بان يعني كل الخطوط تنكشف وموسكو ستصل الى
كل المعلومات وسيحاسب المخطئ ومن يعني
تجرا على القيام بهذه الخطوه لذلك الموضوع
هو الدراسه نايف الجميع يتذكر بان هذا
الملف هو خط احمر مشبه يعني يشابه بشكل
كبير يعني تلك الواقعه في الخليفه الماضي
عندما تم استهداف شبه جزيره القرم ايضا
موسكو راحت بعدها وناقشت القضيه مع مجلس
الامن الروسي واتخذت القرار واستهدفت
البنيه التحتيه وملف الطاقه في الاراضي
الاوكرانيه لذلك كل الخيارات متاحه نايف
لكن الشيء المختلف الوحيد بين قضيه شبه
جزيره القرم وقضيه المسيرات فوق الكرملين
هو الوقت في البدايه والسريه التي تعمل
بها موسكو من الناحيه الاخرى شديد هل
اعلنا عن اي اجتماع مع مجلس الامن الروسي
قريب
يعني ننتظر اجتماع بين الرئيس الروسي
ومجلس الامن قد يعقد اليوم حسب التوقعات
لكن هو اجتماع مغلق قد يصدر بيان بعده او
لا يصدر كما هي العاده خلال الاونه
الاخيره شكرا جزيلا لكن بما يخص قضيه
احتفال عيد النصر نايف السيناريو في موسكو
ما زال قائما لا تغيير عليه تفضل شكر من
موسكو مراسل العربيه عبد الجواد الرشد على
كل هذه التفاصيل والمعلومات
ارتفعت مستوياته المياه قرب سد نوفا الى
نحو قياسي قد تغمر معها هذا السد الرئيسي
جنوب اوكرانيا نقلا عن وكاله تاسر للانب
الروسيه كما وحذر ريناد كارشا مستشار
المدير العام لشركه الطاقه النوويه
الروسيه ان هذا الارتفاع الكياسي ينذر
بتصدع السد في المياه ستغمر خط الكهرباء
الواصل الى محطات الضخم في محطه زبوجيا
التي تسيطر عليها موسكو مضيفا ان هذا
سيؤدي الى مشاكل فنيه لتشغيل المحطه
ومخاطر على السلامه النوويه
[موسيقى]
اعلنها جيك سوليفان مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي انه سيزور المملكه العربيه
السعوديه في مطلع الاسبوع لاجراء محادثات
مع قادتها ومناقشه مجالات جديده للتعاون
بين نيودلهي والخليج وكذلك الولايات
المتحده وبقيه المنطقه سليمان قال ان خفض
التصعيد والتخلص من الارهاب هو من اولويات
الاداره الامريكيه في الشرق الاوسط واشار
ايضا الى ان الولايات المتحده ستتخذ
الاجراءات الضروريه لمنع ايران من امتلاك
النووي وانها ستسمح ايضا لاسرائيل باتخاذ
اللازمه في حال اقدمت ايران على امتلاك
هذا السلاح وفي سياق متصل قال انه سيتم
الاعلان عن زياره رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
من يمين نتنياهو الى واشنطن في الوقت
المناسب ما في الشان اليمني فقد اعلن
سولفا انه تم اتخاذه عدد من الاجراءات
لخفض التصعيد هناك
السعوديه في مطلع الاسبوع لاجراء محادثات
مع قادتها اذ تسعى الولايات المتحده الى
تطوير شركتها مع الرياض كذلك سيزور ممثلون
للهند والامارات السعوديه
لمناقشه مجالات جديده للتعاون بين نيودلهي
والخليج وكذلك الولايات المتحده وبقيه
المنطقه وسوف نعلن عن زياره نتنياهو الى
واشنطن في الوقت المناسب
رمز
دعوني اذكر بما سبق ان قاله الرئيس بايدن
بنفسه وهو ان التزامنا نحو الشرق الاوسط
افريقيا ثابت لا يهتز لان هذه المنطقه
مهمه جدا من اجل مستقبلنا ومصالحها تتشابك
مع مصالح الولايات المتحده
وشركائنا الاخرين
ان اربعه دبلوماسيين اذربيجانين بينهم
اثنان من سفاره اذربيجان في طهران من
القنصليه العامله في تبريز عناصر غير
مرغوب بها للبقاء على الاراضي الايرانيه
وياتي اعلان طيران بعد الهجوم الذي وقع في
السفاره الاتربيجانيه في العاصمه
الايرانيه واعلان باكو طرد اربعه موظفين
بالسفاره الايرانيه في باكو باعتبارهم
عناصر غير مرغوب بها
طلب وزير الخارجيه الايطاليه انطونيو
تجانب اعتذار بشان ما تعدها روما تصريحات
مهينه طلب بعضها ازمه المهاجرين الذين
يصلون بالقوارب كما الغى تجاني زياره كانت
مقرره الى باريس وذلك بعد اتهام وزير
الداخليه الفرنسيه رئيسه الوزراء
الايطاليه جورجيا ميلوني بانها عاجزه عن
حل مشاكل الهجره في بلادها معتبرا تلك
التصريحات بانها مهينه وغير مقبوله
هلوه بين فرنسا وايطاليا تتعمق اكثر فاكثر
باريس تنتقد وروما تستنكر ملف الهجره يوتر
العلاقات بين البلدين
الفرنسي جيرال دارمانعه
بالعجز عن حل مشاكل الهجره في بلادها
قال ان حكومه اليمين المتطرف التي اختارها
اصدقاء مارينلوبين عاجزه عن ايجاد حلول
لمشاكل الهجره بعد من انتخبت على هذا
الاساس تصريحات اثارت حفيظه الحكومه
الايطاليه على خلفيه ذلك وزير الخارجيه
الايطالي انطونيو تاجاني الغى زياره كانت
مقرره الى باريس لن اذهب الى باريس
للمشاركه في الاجتماع الذي كان مقررا
اهانات وزير الداخليه جيرال دارمانان بحق
الحكومه وايطاليا غير مقبوله وز الخارجيه
الفرنسيه حاولت ان تخفف من حده التوتر اذ
اكدت ان فرنسا تريد العمل مع ايطاليا
لمواجهه تحدي الزياده السريعه في تدفق
المهاجرين بغض النظر عن تصريحات وزير
الداخليه
التعاون بين البلدين يرتكز في هذا الشان
على المهاجرين من وسط البحر الابيض
المتوسط لكن هذا التعاون ورجوع العلاقات
الى حالها الطبيعي امران قد يحتاجان الى
بعض الوقت حتى تعود المياه الى مجاريها
بلال البجدين العربيه
بعد اقتتام الرئيس الايراني ابراهيم رئيس
زياره استمرت اليومين الى دمشق رحب بيان
مشترك لسوريا وايران بالتطورات السياسيه
الاخيره الايجابيه التي تشهدها المنطقه
خاصه فيما يتعلق بتوصل سوريا البناء مع
الدول العربيه وكذلك الاتفاق الايراني
السعودي حيث اكد البيان ان السيئناف
العلاقات بين الرياض وطهران بواسطه صينيه
في مارس الماضي يشكل خطوه مهمه نحو مزيد
من التطورات الايجابيه التي تخدم استقرار
الشرق الاوسط البيان المشترك شدد على
ضروره التضامن والتماسك بين دول المنطقه
لمواجهه التحديات وتوفير الامن والهدوء
عبر التعاون الاقليمي كما واعرب الجانبان
عن استعدادهما لتطوير العلاقات التجاريه
والاقتصاديه مركزين على سبل تطوير التعاون
القائم على اعاده اعمار سوريا
شركه الجاليه التركيه في المانيا في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه التركيه واقترع
الالاف مرشحهم المفضل طوال الايام الماضيه
ويحق لمليون ونصف المليون تركي يعيشون في
المانيا التصويت في الانتخابات وفي
السنوات الماضيه صوتوا بمعظمهم للرئيس
الحالي رجب طيب اردوغان
قرابه المليون
يعيشون في المانيا يحق لهم المشاركه
بالانتخابات الرئاسيه التركيه وهنا امام
القنصليه التركيه في برلين صفوف طويله من
الناخبين يصطفون للادلاء بصوتهم اصوات
الاتراك في المانيا تذهب بمعظمها بحسب
اتجاهات التصويت في السنوات الماضيه
للرئيس الحالي رجب طيب اردوغان ومع ذلك
هذه المره كانت المعارضه حاضره هنا وان
بصوره خجوله معظم الاتراك في المانيا
الذين قدموا بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه
كانوا مهاجرين عمال ومكثوا هنا كثيرون
منهم ما زالوا يشعرون بارتباط قوي مع
تركيا وكثيرون ايضا خاصه الكبار في السن
لا يحملون الجنسيه الالمانيه حتى
اردوغان لديه صوره القائد القوي الذي
يمكنه ان يواجه الغرب والاتراك الذين
يعيشون في المانيا يحبون هذه الصوره وكذلك
هم لا يتاذون من الوضع الاقتصادي في تركيا
الواصلون الجدد الى المانيا من المعارضين
السياسيين مثل حسين ديمير واجوزان البيرق
الذين لجاوا بعد الانقلاب الفشل ياملون ان
تحمل الانتخابات في تركيا تغييرا قد ينعكس
عليهم
امل ان تفوز المعارضه فهم وعدوا بانهم
سيحترمون حقوق الانسان ويعيدون العمل
بالقانون وهذا يعني ان كل الاتهامات
الباطله سيتم رفعها وسيصبح القضاء مستقلا
اصوات الاتراك في الخارج تشكل قرابه
الثلاثه نصفهم يصوتون في المانيا ما يعني
ان اصوات الاتراك هنا قد تحدث فرقا في حال
كان الاقبال مرتفعا وهو ما يبدو الحال
عليه هذا العام راغب بهنام العربيه برلين
الى تركيا حيث اجواء من الترقب تسود اوساط
اللاجئين السوريين هناك خاصه وان ملف
وجودهم في تركيا تحول الى محور جدال بين
الحكومه والمعارضه وبينما يامل كثيرون فوز
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان مجددا اكد عدد من
السوريين الحاصلين على الجنسيه التركيه
انهم سيصوتون لبقائه في سده الحكم
اللاجئون السوريون في تركيا ومنذ اكثر من
عقد طرف مهم في لعبه التدافع السياسي بين
الحكومه التركيه والمعارضه تاره يلوح
الرئيس التركي بورقه اللاجئين بوجه اوروبا
واخرى يقول ان بامكان السوريين العوده
طوعا الى وطنهم على الجانب الاخر يعد اكبر
احزاب المعارضه حزب الشعب الجمهوري بحل
مشكله المهاجرين واللاجئين خلال عامين
معتبرا ان الحكومه التي خلقت المشكله لا
يمكنها حلها هذا الخلاف دفع بعض اللاجئين
للتعبير عن املهم بفوز الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان في الانتخابات بينما اقل سوريون
حاصلون على الجنسيه التركيه بانهم سيصوتون
من بين اللاجئين نيروز وزوجها عادل الذين
فرام من مدينه عين العرب الى تركيا عام
2015 وعبر عن املهما بان يحظى اردوغان
بولايه رئاسيه جديده
تركيا وطني الثاني واتمنى فوز اردوغان في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه لانه سيساعدنا على
البقاء هنا ولد اطفالنا الاربعه هنا وهم
لا يعرفون سوريا وقد تمارس المعارضه علينا
ضغوطا كي نعود الى سوريا
سوريون اخرون حصلوا على الجنسيه التركيه
عبر الاستثمار او دراسه تخصصات معينه منهم
حسين عتبه الذي سيصوت للمره الاولى كمواطن
تركي واكد ان صوته الانتخابي سيكون
لارضوان
نتشاطر انا واصدقائي الراي في ملف
اللاجئين وايضا في الملف الاقتصادي لاننا
نرى ما فعله اردوغان من اجل البلد وحتى
موعد الرابع عشر من الشهر الجاري سيكون
ملف اللاجئين السوريين احد اهم موضوعات
الانتخابات الرئاسيه كما كان الحال عام
وسيحبس اللاجئون انفاسهم لمعرفه ما ان
سيتغير ساكن القصر الرئاسي ام لا حسن
جوليد العربيه
استكملت السلطات البريطانيه استعدادها
لحفل تتويج الملك تشارلز الثالث منذ عقود
ادى الملكوت تشارلز الثالث اهتماما
بالتعرف على ثقافه العربيه والفن الاسلامي
كانت المنطقه العربيه وجهته او وجهته
الاولى
اثراء زوال القيود المفروضه على السفر
خلال جائحه كورونا
[موسيقى]
ليس سرا ان الملك تشارز الثالث اقام
علاقات وثيقه مع العائلات الحاكمه في دول
الخليج ودول عربيه اخرى منذ عقود فعلى
مدار سنوات زار الملك تشارلز اثنتي عشره
دوله عربيه عده مرات
ركزت بشكل اساسي على تعزيز روابط بريطانيا
بها وبناء الثقه وفي طلعتها السعوديه التي
حل ضيفا عليها 10 مرات والتقى مع قادتها
بدءا من الملك فهد والملك عبد الله الى
الملك سلمان وولي عهده لارساء التواصل بين
مسؤول البلدين على اعلى المستويات والحفاظ
على الطابع الشخصي للعلاقات
اعتقد ان هذه الروابط ستستمر وعندما يقول
احدهم انه كان يقيم تلك العلاقات فاراها
انها اتت بشكل طبيعي من شخص كان مهتما حقا
بما قراه وما لاحظه بالاضافه الى انه شخص
عميق التفكير للغايه ولديه احساس قوي جدا
بالواجب الذي قام به حتى في ذلك الوقت وهو
يدرك ان دوره المستقبلي سيكون ملكا
لبريطانيا الحديثه يعرف عن الملك تشارلز
انه من اشد المهتمين بالثقافه العربيه
والاسلاميه في الغرب ويعتبر هذا الاهتمام
جزءا من رؤيته الشامله للتعايش والتفاهم
بين الثقافات المختلفه وهو من الداعمين
للحوار الدولي بين الاديان كاحد الوسائل
الفعاله لتعزيز السلام والتعاون بين
الشعوب
اتذكر محاضره القاها الملك عن الاسلام
والغرب في اكتوبر عام 93 واست فيها تعبيرا
عربيا يقول الذي يخرج من القلب يدخل القلب
والذي يخرج من اللسان لا يتجاوز الاذان
والقوه الحقيقيه لتلك المحاضره انها جاءت
من القلب وما كان يلفت انتباهنا هو اننا
لا نستطيع ان نعيش في سوء الفهم بين
العالمين الاسلامي والغربي والصور النمطيه
عن بعضنا البعض في اول زياره خارجيه لاحد
افراد العائله الملكيه البريطانيه منذ
جائحه كورونا زار الملك تشارلز رفقه
قرينته الملكه
واتفقد اثارها التاريخيه والجامعه الازهر
كما سبقت زيارته لمسجد الشيخ زايد في اطار
تعزيز قيم التسامح الديني واحترام
التعدديه الثقافيه
شارك في العديد من المناسبات الثقافيه
والتراثيه العربيه ومنها مهرجان الجنادريه
بالرياض ورقص بالسيف متشحا الزي السعودي
الخاصه بالعرضه للملك تشارلز الثالث
علاقات وثيقه مع العالم العربي
ولطالما شجع على التفاهم والاحترام
المتبادل بنى الاديان وثقافات من منطلق ان
فهم الثقافه الاسلاميه والعربيه بشكل افضل
يمكن ان يساعد على تعزيز هذا الحوار
وتعميق فهم الاخرين مصطفى زاروه العربيه
وهذه صور مباشره من لندن العاصمه
البريطانيه وقصر
والتحضيرات ايضا كذلك
الجاريه والتي تجري طبعا منذ اشهر
لتتويج تشارلز الثالث ملكا لبريطانيا
ومعنا من لندن مراسله العربيه عروض عبد
الحق عروب مرحبا بك معي في هذه الساعه كيف
تجري التحضيرات في لندن في عموم ايضا حتى
وباقي المدن البريطانيه لهذا اليوم الذي
يوصف بانه مهم تاريخي في البلاد لتتويج
تشارلز الثالث ملكا لبريطانيا
مرحبا نايف يعني ربما الجو في لندن الماطر
لم يساعد الكثير من البريطانيين والمقيمين
الذين توافدوا الى هذه المنطقه اليوم ولكن
يمكن القول بان الجوجو احتفالي بامتياز في
العاصمه البريطانيه نحن الان في منطقه دير
من قبل قليل منذ حوالي الساعه تقريبا
راينا سياره الملك تشارلز تخرج من هذا
المكان طبعا الموكب الذي رافقه وعلمنا بان
الملك تشارلز ربما او علمنا بان الملك
تشارلز قام بالتحضيرات النهائيه او بروفا
نهائيه لمراسم التتويج التي ستنطلق غدا
صباحا قبل الملك تشارلز ايضا كان الامير
ويليام قد خرج من نفس المكان ونحن نعلم ان
انه سيكون للامير وليم دور كبير غدا في
تتويج في حفل تتويج والده طبعا هذه
المنطقه دير هي المنطقه التي سيصل اليها
الملك تشارلز غدا الساعه الحاديه عشره
وسينطلق من قصر باكينج في الساعه العاشره
والثلث صباحا غدا في موكب هذا هذا الموكب
سيستخدم فيه عربه اليوبيل الماسي تصل الى
ديرب منستر ومن ثم تتم مراسم التتويج
حوالي في حوالي الساعتين تقريبا ومن ثم
يخرج
منستر في موكب اخر او مسيره اخرى اضخم من
حيث العدد منستر الى قصر من حيث طبعا عدد
القوات الحرس الملكي وقوات الجيش
البريطاني الذي ستشارك في هذه المسيره نحن
نتوقع يعني مشاركه حوالي السته الاف عنصر
من قوات الحرس الملكي ومن قوات الجيش
البريطاني بالاضافه الى قوات من جيوش دول
اخرى من المعروف التي تعرف بانها دول
الكومنويل يعني نحن نعلم بان الملك
تشارلسي ينصب ملكا غدا فقط على المملكه
المتحده وانما على اربع عشره دوله اخرى من
دول الكومنويل ونحن نعلم بان العاصمه او
بريطانيا بشكل عام يعني لم تشهد حفل تتويج
لشخصيه ملكيه منذ اكثر من 70 عام منذ عام
1953 عندما توجت الملكه اليزابيث الراحله
على راس يعني العرش البريط سنتابع معك كل
هذه التفاصيل سواء اليوم او غدا ايضا في
هذا اليوم الهام
لبريطانيا وللدول الكومنويل شكرا جزيلا لك
مراسله العربيه عرب عبد الحق
[موسيقى]
اذا صيف حار بانتظار العالم ان صحت
التوقعات فتحذيرات الامم المتحده من تشكل
الظاهره المناخيه الينين وهذا العام تؤرق
العلماء وتزيد المخاوف من تاثيراتها
السلبيه على العالم
ارتفاع متسارع في درجات حراره المحيطات
يؤرق العلماء ويزيد المخاوف من تاثير على
الاحتباس الحراري
تحذيرات اطلقتها الامم المتحده ترجح تشكل
ظاهره المناخيه هذا العام ما قد يدفع
درجات الحراره الى معدلات قياسيه جديده
اما المنظمه العالميه للارصاد الجويه
فتوقعت تشكل الظاهره بحلول نهايه يوليو
بنسبه 60% وبحلول نهايه سبتمبر بنسبه 80%
النينيو ظاهره مناخيه طبيعيه تحدث في
المتوسط كل سنتين الى سبع سنوات وتستمر
عاده من تسعه الى 12 شهرا وترتبط عموما
بارتفاع درجات الحراره وزياده الجفاف في
بعض انحاء العالم وبامطار غزيره في مناطق
اخرى ظاهره المينيو حدثت اخر مره في 2018
واتاحتت المجال لحلقه طويله من ظاهره
الميلينيا التي تسبب اثارا عكسيه خصوصا
درجات الحراره لهذه الظاهره المناخيه
عواقب وخيمه وتعتمد اثارها جزئيا على
التوقيت حيث تهدد النينيو الحياه البحريه
بالدرجه الاولى لان الاسماك لا تستطيع
مقاومتها ومقاومه درجات الحراره المرتفعه
اما تاثيره على البشر فلا يقل ضررا حيث
يمكن ان تسبب الاعاصير وسط المحيط الهادئ
وشرقه كارثه تضرب السواحل فيما تتسبب
بالجفاف في جزء اخر من الارض ما يهدد
مصادر الغذاء العالمي المهدده اصلا بفعل
الجفاف وتغير المناخ
ذات ظاهره الينينو او مدتها لا يمكن
توقعها فموجتها الاخيره اعتبرت ضعيفه
مقارنه بالتي حدثت بين عامي 2014
وكانت لها عواقب وخيمه اياد حمود العربيه
هذه الساعه الاخباريه انتهت الزميل
ابراهيم بدر القاكم على راس الساعه
المقبله في رعايه الله
سيدنا الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات